Jean-Yves Le Drian appel à une relation
apaisée entre la France et l'Algérie le
ministre français des Affaires
étrangères et à Alger hier il s'est
entretenu avec le président algérien des
magies Teboul après plus de 2 mois de
crise diplomatique à l'origine de la
brouille les propos tenus par Emmanuel
Macron il a fait accuser le système
politique au militaire algérien
d'entretenir une rente mémorielle autour
de la guerre d'indépendance et de la
France la correspondance au Maghreb de
Bassam chaabi
une rencontre placé sous le signe de la
reprise du dialogue et de l'Avenir entre
la France et l'Algérie hier après un
entretien avec son homologue Rammstein
Lamamra Jean-Yves Le Drian a rencontré
le président algérien au palais
d'El-Mouradia dans l'espoir d'une
reprise du dialogue après la crise
diplomatique enclenche en octobre
dernier par le chef de l'État français
selon des propos rapportés par nos
confrères du journal Le Monde le
locataire de l'Élysée accusé Alger
d'entretenir une haine de la France est
une rente mémorial autour de la guerre
d'indépendance avant de qualifier le
pouvoir algérien de système politique au
militaire il fallait pas moins pour
provoquer la colère de l'autre rive de
la Méditerranée déjà palpable après
l'annonce de Gabriel Attal le
porte-parole de l'Élysée de la réduction
de 50 % du nombre de visa pour le
territoire français accordé aux
candidats algérien à l'occasion d'une
conférence de presse donner à l'issue de
la rencontre entre les deux hommes le
diplomate français à réitérer la volonté
de Paris d'oublier les discordes pour
regarder vers l'avenir écouter
nous souhaitons que le dialogue que nous
relançons aujourd'hui puisse conduire à
une reprise des échanges politique entre
nous deux gouvernement en 2022 au-delà
des blessures du passé que nous devons
regarder en face au regard des
malentendus qu'il nous revient de
dépasser la France et l'Algérie faut
qu'on fasse ensemble à les défis majeurs
dans un environnement régionale et
international un certain surtout ces
sujets et parce que nous intéressons
comment notre concertation est
primordial et c'était le sens de ma
présence aujourd'hui à Alger
comme une volonté réelle d'Emmanuel
Macron
après les propos du président français
est interdit aux avions militaires
français de l'opération barkhane au Mali
son espace aérien alors et des relations
entre Alger et Paris ne ferai que
décrédibiliser l'action militaire
française au Sahel sur un continent ou
la beauté africaine de s'affranchir
d'une forme de dépendance vis-à-vis de
l'Europe à part et elle de plus en plus
palpable avec ce nouveau geste
d'apaisement la France semble jouer ses
dernières cartes pour protéger ses
intérêts en Afrique de peur sûrement
devoir sa position privilégiée et
historique avec son ancienne colonie de
l'Afrique and basculer au profit de
puissance comme la Chine ou la Russie